hello everyone and welcome to the most
requested game from CH yesterday's
Champion Chester finals it is round five
game between Wesley so and Magnus
Carlson this is the third game of round
five two first two rapid games ended in
a draw and this is now the Armageddon
game so Magnus needs a draw in order to
win Wesley needs to win in order to win
Armageddon I'm also going to show
another game in this video H but let's
focus on this one first and regarding
clock times yes I've heard your comments
and I will uh stop using them for the
moment as you guys said that you like
them but you don't like them changing
colors all the time so you know it This
is distracting from the actual game so
until I fix that I'm not going to
visually use the times uh on the clock
but you know hopefully I will be able to
do it fairly soon and uh yeah it wasn't
really an issue for this game or the
other one that I'm going to show uh so
you know don't worry about the clocks in
this one let's just enjoy the chest so
Wesley opened with Pawn to E4 and Magnus
goes for Pawn to C5 which is very solid
for for an Armageddon game that you only
need a draw in Knight to C3 we have
Knight to C6 and now Knight to F3 we
have Pawn to E5 and now Bishop to C4 and
already after G6 we have a completely
new game that's um very very interesting
as you know move four in Sicilian
Defense getting a completely new game
not something you see every day so okay
Pawn to D3 we have H6 and now Wesley
goes for Pawn to H3 we have Pawn to D6
and now Knight to H2 already saying that
he wants the castle and execute Pawn to
F4 uh Bishop to G7 by Magnus we have
castles Knight to F6 and now Pawn to F4
striking in the center e captures Bishop
captures and now Castles by Magnus we
have Queen to D2 now preparing to
capture on H6 so Magnus just defends it
with King to H7 we have Knight back to
F3 as the Knight no longer has a purpose
on H2 and now Bishop to E6 countering
the strong light Square Bishop here and
now uh there are a couple moves you
could consider like moving the bishop
back or capturing on E6 but Wesley does
nothing of the sort he plays Knight to
G5 check sacrifices the Knight and
starts an attack against the black king
and it's a very weird sacrifice because
it's unclear what your plan is after
Magnus accepts the sacrifice and
accepting is definitely the strongest
move so that's what Magnus does we have
Bishop captures now okay the Knight is
pinned but it is defended twice uh so
Knight to E5 getting another defender in
also putting pressure on the bishop and
just Queen to F2 and now Wesley's idea
becomes apparent he wants to play Queen
H4 check and put even more pressure on
that Knight on F6 so Magnus goes Knight
E to D7 he adds another Defender and now
Pawn to E5 Wesley gives up a little bit
more material to clear the E4 Square for
his Knight and put even more pressure on
that F6 Knight so okay D captures on E5
we have Knight to E4 and now the
question is how to defend this it's a
really nasty position and um uh there
are many ways to go wrong and there's
pretty much only one way to go right the
idea that Magnus has to find here is
Bishop to F5 and King to G8 those are
the two moves that have to be uh
included in this defense and to give you
an idea uh once let's say King G8
because he was not played in the game
now okay Queen to H4 you put more
pressure here now Bishop to F5
disconnects the rook's attack towards
the Knight on F6 and now after let's say
Knight G3 you go after the F F5 Bishop
now Queen to B6 and now black can defend
and will be even better if Rook captures
on F5 G captures and Knight captures
there's a very nice defensive maneuver
Knight to H7 goes after the bishop and
once the bishop moves now you play
Bishop F6 go after the queen and once
the queen moves King to h8 and now
you've defended if Knight to H6 going
after the F7 Pawn you don't care Rook a
to d8 you give up The Rook here captures
captures and captures and now Queen B4
you offer a queen trade and you are
perfectly fine you will break the
position with E4 and your position is
excellent here however this is uh you
know easy the spot but the move order
matters because Magnus wanted to play it
but he started with Queen to B6 and now
after Queen to B6 it's a completely
different variation because now after
Queen to H4 which comes with check King
to G8 uh you can no or rather you can no
longer play King to G8 you'd be great if
you could now play King to G8 and Bishop
to F5 but what happens now is that
Wesley will just play Rook captures on
F6 and you're not in time Knight
captures Knight captures with check you
have to capture and you get checkmated
on h8 so now after this IDE of Queen to
H4 check Magnus cannot afford King G8 he
has to play Knight to H5 and now Pawn to
G4 again uh not uh devastating for for
uh BL but uh you have to find the
precise move and Magnus doesn't the only
way to defend this is Pawn to F5 to show
you F5 will be met with G captures on H5
and now you will play F captures on e4
and after H captures and G6 check you
have to go to G6 with the king and you
are very safe here if King to H2 trying
to play play Rook to G1 now you just
play Knight to F6 and you take care of
everything uh because okay the F6 square
is nicely defended three times by the
bishop rook and the king and if you go
Rook to G1 then the king escapes via F7
with the Knight nicely uh guarding
everything uh but Magnus missed it he
played Bishop captures on C4 first
probably with the idea that once Wesley
recaptures he will then play Pawn to F5
maybe he just wanted to get rid of one
one more attacker from the board but
Wesley Now does not capture back he just
plays G captures on H 5 and now the
position is uh is lost uh Magnus played
Bishop to D5 even though okay if you try
F5 now yeah you can play it but it's not
going to be easy Knight to G3 and after
Bishop to D5 n just going to play H
captur and G6 for example and there's
nothing here yeah King King goes to G if
you go capture here then this is
Checkmate if you go to G8 then this is
Checkmate so uh not great Magnus played
Bishop to D5 first he wanted to save the
bishop but now Wesley goes for Knight to
F6 six with check very nasty stuff here
Knight captures on F6 and now of course
Rook captures on F6 it comes with an
attack on the black queen and now if you
play Bishop captures and F6 the problem
is H captures and G6 check King captures
and queen to H6 check of course King
goes to F5 Rook to F1 with check King E6
and now Rook captures on F6 will pick up
the queen on B6 so that why that's one
of the reasons why King to G8 in that
line was crucial not to allow all of
these tactics so Queen captures on F6
was played Magnus gives up the queen
right away Bishop captures with have uh
Pawn to G5 now and queen captures and G5
Bishop captures Queen sorry not Queen
captures first Wesley delivered a check
King to G7 and now Pawn to H6 with check
playing precise moves we have captures
captures King to H7 Queen to F5 check
King H6 a repetition here once King H7
and now King to F2 preparing to bring
the Rook into the game Rook to G8 and
now of course Queen H4 check King to G6
uh sorry King to G6 and Rook to G1 with
check King to F5 and now uh Queen to H7
with check so if you don't want to lose
the Rook on G8 you have to block with
the Rook so Rook to G6 and only now
wastle traded Rook captures Pawn
captures and now Queen to D7 with check
so Magnus does have some compensation
for the queen uh in the likes of the
rook and the the bishop here but the
black king being on F5 it's very very
hard to escape all of the checks Bishop
to E6 but now Queen captur some B7
Wesley starts collecting material you
want to get rid of all the pawns and
then you will just start pushing your
own pawns that's the easiest way to win
uh Rook to h8 was played and now King to
G3 but we all know how resilient Magnus
is so he will of course fight this we
have G5 Queen to G7 now attacking the
rook and Rook to H4 we have Pawn to B3
and now Pawn to A5 Magnus will try to
create some sort of a fortress but it is
very difficult because you know you
cannot defend those Queens side pawns so
Pawn A4 uh Ponto E4 now trying to get
some action against the white king D
captures sorry that's not a d captures D
captures King captures and now Queen to
G6 check again you have to block with
the bishop Queen to C6 check and now
more pawns will fall King to d uh D4
defending the C5 Pawn but now even C3
with check and it's not that Wesley
wants to trade pawns here he actually
wants captur and queen to F6 check to
pick up the bishop on F5 so King to E5
that's why Magnus goes back uh Queen
captures on C5 check King to F6 and
queen to B6 with check Bishop to E6 and
now just King to G2 not allowing any
checks uh any captures to come with
check uh and now just Rook to E4 of
course if uh you go for a capture here
then just Queen captures on E6 and it's
a completely winning end game for Wesley
King F5 just B4 and that's it of course
the the the pawns just start marching
forward so Magnus play Rook to E4 but it
doesn't matter Pawn to B4 we have
captures captures Rook to E2 check King
G3 Rook to A2 and now Queen to D4 with
check King to F5 uh and now Queen to D3
with check trying to connect with the
with something but U um you know more
more more than anything just guarding
against any unnecessary checks that
might be delivered to the white king So
King to E5 Now Pawn to A5 Wesley just
starts pushing and that's pretty much it
Bishop to D5 trying to get some sort of
a uh Checkmate here but of course Queen
to E3 with check King to F5 Queen to D3
check King E5 and now King to G4 uh Rook
to G2 with check King to H5 now Bishop
to E4 and queen to C3 with check King F4
Now Pawn to A6 uh and here Magnus did
play Rook to C2 but he was also in this
position on move 59 that he resigned the
game as there is nothing more to be done
here he had like 40 seconds on the clock
I think Westley had like two and a half
minutes so it's not really an issue of
time but once the queen moves like Queen
F6 check the pawns just start marching
forward uh then this Pawn defends it and
I mean it's it's too easy to win this of
course Magnus will not suffer through
this uh so beautiful game by Wesley and
by drawing two first two rapid games and
winning Armageddon Wesley wins the match
and not just by drawing an Armageddon by
actually winning a game against Magnus
so very nicely done by Wesley and uh
yeah you've seen that position very very
early on in the game uh how uh he went
for this um uh all the tricky moves you
know push G4 and uh just started
capturing everything set up this
beautiful Knight sacrifice on G5 even
though it's not a move you will see uh
even if Wesley started this position
it's not a move that the engine
recommends it's not like in the first
five suggestions so Knight to G5 uh it's
possible to defend but you know you have
to play precise and it's always easier
to attack them to defend and this one
goes to Wesley now that being said let's
check out another game this one is from
round six uh the one also you guys
requested features Magnus versus Maxim
Vash gra and it's ALS also a pretty wild
one let me just check the letter on the
little robot so you guys don't think
this is a an Armageddon game as well uh
so just give me a few seconds there we
go all right so this is a rapid game and
Magnus in this one had the white pieces
and he opened with Knight to F3 so let's
see what Maxim goes for we have Pawn to
D5 C4 at the uh the reti Gambit and now
Pawn to E6 again transposing into the
ainur defense G3 Knight to F6 Bishop to
G2 and Bishop to E7 both players castled
and here we have Pawn to B3 Magnus
signaling that he will now fin to his
other Bishop as well D4 we have Pawn to
E3 and now Knight to C6 again D3 looks
like a really awesome move because it
sort of cripples White's uh center of
the board but after Knight to E5 it's
very very hard to find moves for black
here to give an example let's say you
want to get rid of this Knight just F4
will be played and you can even double
wh's Pawns here let's say Knight goes
here uh immediately Bishop to A3 you
kick away the rook and once The Rook
moves you have immense problems here the
F7 Pawn is hanging and there's no good
way to defend it because the bishop
controls all of the dark squares here
and if you play G6 again there's no good
move here let's say you play C5 you cut
off the bishop Rook captures on F7 and
you you you just uh lose the game let's
say Knight to C3 will come here and then
Rook to F1 will deliver Checkmate to the
black king so it's a you know uh don't
try something like D3 here so Knight to
C6 by Maxim and now e captures and D4
Knight captures and now just Bishop to
B2 Magnus fetto the other Bishop as well
and there are a couple of games where
Knight captures and F3 was played but
here we have Bishop to C5 and it is now
already as of move nine that we have a
completely new game uh so Magnus
develops Knight C3 we have Rook E8 and
now Knight to E5 getting sort of a
Catlin setup here uh we have Bishop to
D6 and now Pawn to F4 so with the f file
now uh F Pawn pushed and this diagonal
opening up uh Maxim brings the bishop
back now threatening all sorts of nasty
discoveries King to H1 and now Queen to
E7 now Maxim has to figure out how to
get his Bishop into the game make
magnus's bishop not that useful and get
the Rook into the game if he can solve
that he will be fine uh if not then
Magnus will just straight up win the
game and Magnus goes for Pawn to G4 it's
always very impressive when you're able
to uh push pawns on the same side that
you've Castle just rattle your
opponent's king also castled on that
same side so we have Rook to d8 pawn to
G5 Knight to D7 and now Knight to E4
just putting the knight in front of your
opponent's king it's always uh you know
a good recipe for victory Knight to f8
Magnus wants to attack the black king
but Maxim wants to create some sort of a
defensive perimeter here uh with the
Knight helping out with the control of
the six Rank and also the H7 Pawn H
Queen to H5 now uh and Knight to G6 and
look at this now Knight to G4 you know
that something will land on either F6 or
H6 and Bishop to A3 now Maxim wants to
trade the Bishops here but now Knight G
to F6 with check and what do you play
here you of course have to capture uh
not just moving end up with Queen
captures on H7 and then you get
destroyed so you have to accept the
sacrifice but now comes G captures on F6
and now with the dark squares opened up
you have to worry about this Checkmate
and you also have to worry about Knight
5 followed by Queen captures on H7 so
how do you play this now the real
problem is uh if Queen to f8 okay you
stop the idea of Queen H6 then comes
Bishop captures an A3 you you just uh
bring the queen back and then Knight G5
and that that's pretty much it and it's
interesting that in the game uh Maxim
tried a different approach he played
Queen to B8 which can be met with the
exact same move Bishop captures on A3
but Magnus goes for Knight to G5 first
and now after King to f8 because there's
really no good way to defend just Queen
captures on H7 uh Rook to D7 was played
and now Bishop captures on D4 and it was
in this position on move 23 that Maxim
Vash resigned the game as there is
nothing more to be done and as the other
game ended in a draw Magnus takes the
win in the rapid section so now you're
down a full piece you cannot capture you
get checkmated on F7 and without that
you really have no useful move here like
any move you make here uh is pretty much
completely useless there's no way to get
the bishop The Rook into the game is
just a uh it's just a failed plan uh
right from the beginning and it's it's
very unclear where uh Maxim got uh has
gone this wrong because up until this
point Knight to C6 yeah probably C5 here
C5 is the the the move that should be
played but even after Knight to C6 he
probably wanted to use it as a surprise
uh it just really went South really
quickly and then a lot of Bishop moves
like Bishop back and forth and already
already at this point after G4 is played
the engine says white is sort of winning
if um uh even even black defends
properly so it's a difficult position
difficult system to play that Maxim
tried to maybe surprise Magnus a little
bit but it didn't work out very well
yeah brilliant brilliant game by Wesley
Magnus was able to bounce back in round
six uh but um yeah Wesley just Wesley
just dominating dominating the event uh
so yeah that's the game or rather those
are the games hope you guys enjoyed it I
would like to thank David gasparian
Nathan I love you Dad Milos K streets
for me and David Kimura for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing to check up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the Chess World so thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your
day